we welcome you back to CBS mornings can
you believe that this week marks one
year since the landmark Supreme Court
decision overturned Roe B Wade sending
the fight over abortion rights back to
the States a CBS News poll out just this
morning finds a majority of Americans 57
percent say overturning row has been
mostly bad for the country in some
places with new restrictions abortion
rights Advocates are turning directly to
the voters to amend state constitutions
to protect access now a CBS News
investigation has found that a
coordinated campaign heavily funded by a
leading Republican Mega donor aimed at
making it harder to pass those
amendments Caitlin Huey Burns joins us
now with that story Caitlin good morning
to you good morning to you Gail well in
the year since Roe v Wade was overturned
voters in Kansas and Michigan voted to
preserve abortion access in their state
constitutions with wide support and we
found that that success has kick-started
a nationwide campaign to quash similar
amendments and that's all all zeroing in
on the state of Ohio
these were the protests that broke out
last month when the Republican dominated
Ohio legislature approved a
controversial plan
lawmakers set a special election in
August to decide whether amending the
state constitution would now need 60
percent approval from Ohio voters up
from just over 50 percent and it's
misleading it's deceptive and if it
weren't so serious it would be laughable
Maureen O'Connor recently retired as the
Republican Chief Justice of the Ohio
Supreme Court she says Republicans are
pushing an election at a time when
turnout is historically low to make it
easier to secure their agenda they're
holding an August election so that they
can have this 60 percent requirement in
time for the November election where
there will be a ballot initiative to
enshrine Reproductive Rights in our
constitution in a poll last year 59
percent of Ohio voters said they
believed abortion should be generally
legal and in Kansas and Michigan last
year amendments preserving abortion
access past with just under 60 percent
approval numbers O'Connor says caught
the eye of Republicans that's why they
chose the sixty percent so this was
strategic very much strategic when you
keep changing the rules and moving the
goal post you are intentionally
silencing the vote of the people and so
yes it's about it's of abortion but it's
about so many other things as well Ohio
Republican Secretary of State Frank
Larose first proposed raising the
threshold to 60 percent last year we
don't want to see a really radical
abortion Amendment put in our state
constitution but is changing the rules
at this state in the game isn't that
stacking the deck no not whatsoever I
mean again
the game as you called it is an ongoing
public conversation about public policy
as abortion rights groups in Ohio raise
funds nationally for a November vote on
the amendment Larose says changing the
state constitution should be rare and
require a broader consensus I've been
consistent all along that this is about
good government this is about protecting
our state constitution from out of state
special interests but as CBS News
investigation discovered this very
proposal was promoted by conservative
out-of-state interests in this 2021 memo
a florida-based non-profit called the
found foundation for government
accountability touted the sixty percent
super majority requirement members of
the committee a lobbyist for the
foundation was the only one to testify
on behalf of the sixty percent measure
when it was first introduced in the Ohio
house I encourage you to support this
resolution increasing the required
support threshold for constitutional
initiatives to 60 percent The Playbook
being executed in Ohio was also executed
in South Dakota and Arkansas Brendan
Fisher is an expert with the political
Finance Watchdog documented he's traced
much of the foundation's support to
Illinois billionaire Richard Uline of
Republican Mega donor and staunch
opponent of abortion rights a foundation
controlled by diculine has given nearly
18 million dollars to fga in April when
the bill appeared to falter we have less
than a week to save Ohio's Constitution
Uline gave more than a million dollars
to a pressure campaign targeting
Republican lawmakers on the fence it's
time for state representative katrona to
stop the liberal takeover of Ohio
doesn't that speak to the very issue
that you are talking about having an
out-of-state donor support a measure in
Ohio well listen there's massive amounts
of money being spent on both sides of
that issue and that's free speech sure
during a campaign but this was during
the time that this was being talked
about in the legislature and a way to
try to persuade Republicans to come on
board with it and it was effective and
those kind of things are done
transparently can we count on a no vote
from you in August yes
on August 8th Ohio voters will get the
final say on what it will take to amend
the state's constitution in order to
change the Constitution shouldn't it be
more difficult Ohioans have operated
since 1912 with this process and it's
worked well so it's not broken and
there's no need to fix it
the foundation for government
accountability declined to comment and
Richard Uline did not respond to our
requests and right now Ohio has a
six-week abortion ban on the books but
it's being held up by the courts in a
constitutional amendment would prohibit
that ban Gail
so Caitlin you just mentioned that
turnout for the August elections is
typically low so what are they expecting
this time yeah I think that's a really
key point and all of this is that last
year's election in August was just eight
percent turnout and in fact Republicans
actually voted to eliminate August
special elections altogether because of
that but for this they brought them back
and critics are concerned that this
means that just a small percentage of
Voters are going to decide how to amend
the State Constitution and this could
actually be a road map for other areas
with the Battle of abortion now put to
the states it's these kinds of
Constitutional Amendments that are
considered the last line of defense for
abortion access Gail all right Caitlin
thank you we'll see how this turns out
thanks a lot